[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh chris mannix covers the
nba sports illustrated their senior nba
writer
i'm looking at you've got all these
boxes there like are you
are you moving in or moving out right
now
this i'm improvising here for a minute i
didn't know my cleaning people were
coming this morning
i'm in my spare bedroom which i just set
up
briefly i i moved in dan and then i just
left it alone like i stopped i'm packing
at some point and never
never finished paulie paulie can
understand that probably knows my speed
we were just talking about russell
westbrook with the performance last
night and then scottie brooks his coach
comes out and says he's the second
greatest point guard of all time what do
you mean uh
i mean he's scott brooks loves russell
westbrook he's had him from the very
beginning
uh and i think part of scott brooks
knows
that the relationship with russell
westbrook
is as important as anything he does as
far as coaching like having a strong
bond with russ brook
that being said there's some merit to
the statistical
argument there i mean how many point
guards
are able to do what russell westbrook
can do
i mean the way that steph curry changed
the position
with his shooting russell westbrook has
changed
with power and speed now we can argue
about
you know the efficiency of it and the
fact that he hasn't won but
statistically speaking when russell
westbrook's career is over
they're not going to be too many point
guards ahead of him in terms of
individual marks
okay but if you were ranking magic's the
best point guard of all time
right yeah oh yeah yeah matches to this
point okay
so second on that list is
um let's do modern era
modern era okay so you eliminate koozie
and the guys koozie wouldn't be in there
but
okay you know in his generation he was
wonderful but oscar would be the
right-handed dribble wouldn't go too
no it would not no i'd play him to his
go
left every time okay so uh who's second
on your list
i would probably take steph curry okay
um
again i think the shooting changed
everything after that i think it's a
coin flip between
isaiah and john stockton those two guys
would be
third and fourth on my modern list but
you have
stats here and we get drunk with stats
who do you
want leading your team because that to
me is a different
you know that's a different question do
i want russell westbrook
who's got all these stats but do i want
him in crunch time do i want him leading
my team and i think that's where the
separation happens for me
okay but would your would your argument
be any different
if in that what was it 2016 playoff
the thunder didn't blow that 3-2 lead
and they went on to win in the finals
they do that maybe oklahoma maybe kevin
durant doesn't leave oklahoma city
and we are probably looking at russell
westbrook through an entirely different
prison i
just don't i don't want to get bogged i
don't get bogged down in one
one bad sequence that changed or
redefined
who russell westbrook is i mean if they
win that series dan
i think we're both looking at russell
westbrook a lot differently
i'll give you that we were just talking
about that earlier this morning before
we started the show that
that series changed the nba i mean
it truly did you go back and look and
then you know here's durant saying hey
i'm not going to win here i'm going to
join the golden state warriors
then russ stays a little while longer
then you know gets bounced around here a
little bit but
there's no way dan there's no way durant
leaves oklahoma city if they win a
championship
i i think he goes on and tries to
establish a dynasty in oklahoma city
that series changed everything yeah
we're talking chris mannix the sports
illustrated senior nba writer
are the lakers okay you know
no right now they're not okay because
lebron
and davis are struggling dennis
schroeder is out and
the dennis schruter absence stand i
think is going to loom large
over these next couple of weeks
schroeder has been one of the engines of
this team throughout the entire season
they were oh 0-4
back in february when schroeder went out
in those health and safety protocols
him being out 10 to 14 days potentially
at the very least coming back right when
the season ends
and having to work himself back into
shape in time for a potential playing
game that's something that we're gonna
be talking about
over the next couple of weeks all that
being said if they can get through the
play-in situation
and get into the regular playoff field
if that's the direction they ultimately
have to go
i just can't bet against lebron i mean
betting against lebron
is like betting on charlie brown to kick
the football like it's
you keep thinking it's not it's gonna
happen but he keeps coming up
with great moments in the postseason so
if they can get through these next
couple of weeks
fight their way into the regular playoff
field i don't know about you but i don't
think the lakers are terrified of utah
or phoenix or even the clippers
there isn't a super team like golden
state in the western conference
that you look at and say a diminished
version of the lakers can't compete with
so
i'm still thinking that the lakers if
they can plow through this turbulent
stretch
uh they are still the front runner in
the west what do you think the
commissioner thought of
lebron james opinion of play in games i
mean lebron
is rocket fuel right to any nba subject
any subject period i mean he
ignites a debate he did this a couple of
months ago uh
when the subject of the all-star game
came up when he said why are we having
an all-star game all of a sudden it went
from kind of a simmering debate
to one that was everywhere lebron
doesn't want to play in the all-star
game should the nba cancel the all-star
game
uh he's kind of doing it again with the
playing game he's not the first player
to do this obviously luca doncic led the
charge on the play-in tournament as well
it is kind of telling though dan
that the two players most critical of
the play-in tournament are two players
on teams that are sitting right there
around the seventh seat
like that's that's and you know who
loves the play in games
steph curry because steph curry needs to
play in games
to be able to get into the playoffs and
look the play in games
i understand there are some wrinkles
that need to be ironed out
moving forward you probably don't need
the seven seed involved
in the future you can probably get away
with the eight nine seed competing as
you did
in the bubble last year but there's no
way you can convince me or anyone that
the play-in tournament
doesn't have way more value than it has
negativity surrounded you mentioned
golden state
look at washington back in january dan
washington was a train wreck they had to
miss two weeks
because of covet protocols in a
different season
they might have rested bradley beal and
said look come back next year we're
gonna get a high draft pick
for you to play with same thing with
russell westbrook instead they
upgrade the trade deadline they get
daniel gafford who's been great for them
and they're in a position right now to
compete for a spot
in the play-in tournament look lebron
can say what he wants
the playing tournament is not going
anywhere this is something
that adam silver advocated for for
several years
before it was instituted this past
season i talked to silver about this
last summer
he is still very much in favor of it so
while i think we'll see an evolution of
it over the next couple of years
the plan tournament is here to stay
chris good to talk to you as always
and uh good luck unpacking or packing
whatever you're doing in your
room there i have literally no idea
what's in some of these boxes
that's uh chris maddox the senior nba
writer sports illustrated
i'll talk to him in a month and the room
will still look the same